thank you I'm a beloved comic actor who
has nothing to do with animation I'm
here to do a time consuming bit about
how time consuming the Oscars are we're
self-aware anyways let's talk about the
importance of kids movies I mean
animation from Snow White to whatever
Pixar movie came out this year animation
has been the genre to keep the kiddos
entertained look we all once had
undeveloped brains and these colorful
baby movies I made distractions I mean
silly cartoons I mean iPad screensavers
I mean films have always been there for
us like a warm comfortable blanket made
for literal babies and even though these
are statistically the most profitable
and most viewed films in the entire show
we're gonna speed right through the
nominees all right we've got four Disney
Pixar movies and one creepy stop-motion
movie we let a beloved director make and
the winner is